le fait est que 99% de tous les gens dans
ce monde recherchent une fête d'
accord 1% des gens ils sont la fête tu
dois être ce jeudi social où
vous avez envie de sortir
jeudi soir c'est  ça va être le meilleur
la meilleure soirée de ta vie je vais
faire
ce film parle de ce que c'est que d'être
un jeune homme à la recherche de lui-même
il est venu ici régulièrement ouais d'accord tu
sais que Cole est un DJ en herbe et il a
un noyau très distinct  groupe d'amis
nous allons quitter Valley d'ici la fin
de l'été nous devons partir d'ici
car il progresse lentement dans sa carrière
est vraiment obligé de choisir
entre sa musique et ses amis je
ne veux pas  passer les cinq années suivantes à
bousculer
ce qui est arrivé à la loyauté Zach l'a pris au
sérieux et son dévouement au
projet son groupe est incroyable hé tu sais
cette fête a l'air un peu raide j'ai
besoin de l'amplifier DJ c'est dur mec ce n'est
pas comme je pensais que ce serait  ça a été
une sorte de cours accéléré mon nom  e est Jason
Stewart Je suis un deejay ici à LA sous
le nom de jeans et j'étais le DJ
il est consultant pour nous sommes vos
amis
J'ai commencé à travailler avec Zack en lui montrant
les ficelles du DJing et en produisant de la musique
mes sons DJ ont une âme  construisez-les à
partir de zéro,
sortez la tête d'un ordinateur portable et lancez
-vous dans ce que le monde réel essaie
de vous dire Je pense que j'ai quelque chose que je
ressens lorsque vous faites un film
comme celui-ci où vous décrivez un
certain style de vie dans un  certaine scène
c'est bien d'être aussi réel que possible Je
travaille très dur pour le rendre légitime
est complètement attaché au personnage
c'est ce que je veux
tout ce qui manquait était un
hashtag au lieu d'en faire juste
la musique ou  à propos de la création de musique,
nous en avons fait une génération, il y
a beaucoup de cœurs qui battent là-bas, le
film parle de trouver votre propre vérité et d'
écouter votre voix Sam sincèrement
talentueux cette musique est faite pour rassembler les
gens et se sentir en paix  Je
pense que nous faisons un film sur nous
c'est notre génération c'est notre musique